we generate a lot of data
analysts estimate that the average
connected person has a digital
interaction
every 30 seconds a big chunk of that
comes from people like me using all
sorts of apps and services throughout
the day whether i walk somewhere
write an email or like a video on social
media
companies use this information to build
digital profiles
which are used to do everything from
cell ads
to analyze photos to train ai
personalize stock portfolios
or customize your netflix feed it's
become
so valuable that governments are making
big moves to protect their citizens data
people already talk about this becoming
not the internet but the splinter net
one famous example tick tock the video
sharing app skyrocketed to popularity in
the us
and later the u.s government labeled it
a national security threat
would you recommend that people download
that up on their phones
tonight tomorrow anytime currently
only if you want your private
information in the hands of the chinese
communist party
to be clear tick tock's parent company
bite dance
has said it hasn't and wouldn't share
data with the chinese government
but i wanted to understand how exactly
my data
could raise national security concerns
let's start here with
my digital profile it's not the profile
you'd see on social media
but a composite of data collected behind
the scenes
every time i use my phone laptop or even
a smart speaker
more and more data gets added to the
profile i'm not sure the average
person fully appreciates the cyber
security risks that are all under
that's stuart madnik he's a professor at
mit and he's been in the cybersecurity
world since the late 70s
tick tock is only one of many ways that
people have of knowing a lot about you
we use google so it knows about our
searching we use
facebook and we communicate with our
friends we share all kinds of videos
yes they're giving their service away
for free but they're gathering the data
take a hypothetical day in my life i use
a sleep timer on my phone which
sets off an alarm at 7am from bed i'll
click on a few breaking news alerts from
overnight
spend a few minutes scrolling through
social media and turn on my smart
speaker to listen to a podcast
before i even get in the shower several
apps on my phone have already collected
my location
private messages contact list and ip
address
which is like a digital address for your
computer that can reveal what part of
the world you're in
if you grant them permission these apps
can exchange data with each other
and potentially store it in several
places around the world
if i signed up for one app using my
login credentials from a social media
site
the new app might be able to see my list
of friends and
latest activity on that site my location
and email data
can be used to give me personalized ads
and
my contact list is accessible by a
number of different apps on my phone
all of this data can paint a pretty
clear picture of our lives
and with all the apps out there i wanted
to know why president trump is singling
out a video sharing app like tick tock
i called my colleague lisa lin she
writes about chinese technology
so tick tock collects a ton of data that
frankly it's not too different from
facebook or google's youtube
tik tok collects your location data tick
tock collects
your ip address tick tock collects the
type of phone you use to log on
and in addition tick tock also collects
everything you do on the app
the key difference bite dance the
company that created tiktok
is based in china and that makes the
trump administration nervous
in the eyes of the trump administration
the data collected by tiktok could be
used by the communist party to compile
dozers of personal information
of millions of americans we're looking
at tick tock we may be banning tick tock
right now there is no smoking gun that
actually proves that tick tock is
sharing data with the chinese government
the trump administration's assertions
are largely based on the assumption that
tick tock will have to share data with
the chinese government when asked
and this is not unfounded because china
has a national security law
that requires companies to cooperate
with national security investigations
white dances said it operates
independently from the chinese
government
but one issue is that national security
in china
can be anything from a terrorism threat
to dissenting with the government
so the trump administration asked tic
toc to set up a us-based company
to operate independently from china it's
part of a big strategy shift after many
years of interconnected apps and systems
for american users
we are now evaluating each instance
where we believe that u.s citizens data
that they have on their phones or in
their system or in their
health care records we want to make sure
that the chinese communist party doesn't
have a way to easily access that
that's where the splinternet or a global
fractured internet
comes in a fractured internet was
something i had to get used to
when i was a correspondent for the
journal based out of shanghai
i say that because in china many of the
u.s applications are not available
for example google has had pulled out
many years ago
facebook is blocked twitter is blocked
so that's what a
fractured global internet will look like
it causes some inconvenience but it just
means that
you have applications to do different
things the splinternet isn't just
disrupting the way data moves across
borders
it's also affecting the way money flows
around the world
so up through from about 2000 to the
mid-2010s around 2016
the growth in investment in the us uh
was on a steady upward trend
the last few years have have seen a
pretty dramatic reversal
that's adam lisenko he tracks foreign
investment from china into the u.s
which has shrunk as the two superpowers
clash over everything from trade to
advanced technologies we've seen signs
that us government has been increasing
scrutiny over chinese investments in u.s
assets that entail
substantial data especially where that
data
covers behaviors or sensitive
information connected to u.s citizens
examples include grinder the the dating
app
patients like me so clearly the writing
has been on the wall that regulators are
concerned about these
these data assets there have already
been a couple of indications where
u.s attention is likely to go next the
executive order targeting wechat for
example
that was released around the same time
that scrutiny over tick tock was really
ramping up
and it's not just china and the u.s
other countries have been taking control
of their internet to varying degrees
like the eu enacting gdpr to protect
data privacy
user data is becoming a sort of
sovereign asset
and countries are moving to protect that
so trump's move
obviously has broader implications
beyond tick-tock
firstly from a bilateral relationship
standpoint
you know this isn't going to help the
u.s china relationship
chinese companies are watching to see
whether or not entering the u.s market
is a worthwhile bet ticktock is the most
successful
chinese technology company in the united
states ever and
if the message that the united states
sends to china
is that that sort of success here just
isn't welcome
then all technology firms from china are
going to be rethinking
their uh future plans and whether or not
they can
or should involve the united states if
you sit back and you try to say what are
the basic principles
underlying the tick top concerns and you
say
does your business in any way shape or
form
have those possible concerns the answer
in most businesses would be yes
as governments tighten control over
their citizens data
the way many companies do business could
get looked at with fresh scrutiny
and that could ultimately affect the way
users like me experience the internet
as my data and global competition become
bound by digital borders